sky news understands portugal has been
removed from the green list for foreign
travel
meaning uk holiday makers can no longer
travel to
any european country without the need to
quarantine on their return
no countries are thought to have been
added to the green list despite
hopes that restrictions would be removed
for holiday hot spots like spanish
and greek islands as well as malta
portugal's removal means there are
currently no
major tourist destinations on the green
list
and those traveling to portugal now face
10 days quarantine
at home when they return well let's just
remind you
of the traffic light system for
international
travel and the government says people
should not travel to a country
on the red list only british or irish
nationals will be allowed to enter the
uk
from places on that list they'll have to
quarantine in a government
chosen hotel for 10 days and take two
covert tests or people are advised not
to travel to countries on the
amber list for holidays but people are
allowed to travel for
essential reasons anyone returning from
an
ambulance country has to quarantine at
home for
10 days and finally the all-important
green list people returning from any of
these destinations don't
need to quarantine unless they test
positive for
covid19 well it's worth remembering
there are strict rules around
testing before and after travel from
any country uh chief political
correspondent john craig
is in westminster john so a slight
tweaking of this traffic-like system and
clearly
uh uh more tightening of the rules the
government trying to be clearer on
people when they should travel and if
they should travel
well this is a terrible blow for many
people who had hoped for a summer
holiday in
portugal uh that portugal would stay on
the so-called green list
or anybody planning to go to the
canaries or the balearics or the
greek islands these the island
destinations had argued that because
there were islands there was a lesser
risk
and therefore they should be moved into
uh onto the into greenless status
uh portugal uh is a big blow because
uh up to now of course it's been the one
major european holiday
destination where you could go without
having to quarantine
for a 10 days at home or even worse in a
hotel
when you come back now what has happened
is that this review was expected we knew
it was coming today
there's a meeting of ministers and
medical advisors this morning
and this decision has been taken
i should say the prime minister gave us
a pretty clear signal yesterday that
this was coming
because he did say that uh the the uh
the government would continue to put
hunt countries on the red or amber list
where necessary
and he said we won't have any head he
has any hesitation in moving countries
from green to amber or red if necessary
not the other way
not from amber or red to green but from
from green
so that was a warning really that
portugal there was a possibility that
portugal was going to be hit
in this way and it has been sky news
understands that so this is what's the
position
we haven't had an official statement
from the department of transport yet we
are expecting it
but we can confidently report that we
understand
this is the position no new holiday
destinations move to the green list
greek islands spanish islands canaries
and so on
malta um so bad news for anyone hoping
to go there
and also uh portugal that's a real blow
as well for all those people
who are currently there or um hoping to
go there in
say later on in june or july or august
the government will no doubt say it's
going to keep all these uh
under review and probably another review
in a few weeks time
but i think many people will who are
looking forward to a summer holiday
will be bitterly disappointed by this
news